you know I'm somebody that's a real big
hoarder of quotes and ideas whenever I
stumble upon something that's
exquisitely well-written I longed to
capture it to clothe it to transcribe it
to basically record it you know
there-there's a manic desire to capture
the river the reverberation of something
magnificent of something beautiful and
so there's all these lines you know that
I have in my head that seemed to apply
to almost every moment of contemplative
exactitude one of them of course is I
look upon this horizon and I think to
myself and all the clocks in the city
began to were and chime oh let not time
deceive you you cannot conquer time in
headaches and in worries vaguely life
leaks away and time will have its fancy
tomorrow or today so that's kind of
depressing right that's about dread
that's about time passing no matter what
but then there's other lines other lines
that inspire me one of those lines for
example can be something like to see the
world in a grain of sand and heaven in a
wild flower hold infinity in the palm of
your hand hold eternity in an hour all
of a sudden everything is radiant
everything is resplendent everything is
beautiful again right you know it's like
when Henry Miller says even a blade of
grass when given proper attention
becomes a magnificent thing in itself so
what does that tell us that something as
mundane as grass can be exquisite that
something as dull as the everyday can
become magnificent resplendent
miraculous divine only if we're able to
tweak our perceptions to shift our
perception through the arresting and
modulation of attention that's why
cinema that's why poetry that's why art
arrests the body mind and thrusts it
towards the numinous and that's such an
important thing and all of a sudden we
become like Dylan Thomas and we feel
inspired and we say I love this moment
so much I will not go gently into that
good night I will rage rage against the
dying of the lights I will practice
random kindness and senseless acts of
beauty because
minds are like parachutes and the only
function when open and Timothy Leary was
right in order to use your head you've
got to go out of your mind it's amazing
how the self is mediated by the ideas
that it is exposed to my very
personality my very quest is shaped and
authored by the bumper stickers by the
words of wisdom that I stumble upon
along the way think about that for a
minute there's a documentary I saw once
it was called in search of the
miraculous and isn't that the search I
mean isn't the search for the divine for
the miraculous for the inconceivably
sublime what life is all about
isn't that what Joseph Campbell talked
about when he talked about the hero's
journey and apotheosis and rebirth and
resurrection right
holy moments the mysterium tremendum F a
scene awesome and again it all comes
down to controlling and mediating our
attention Darwin said it best attention
if sudden and close graduates into
surprise and this into astonishment and
this into stupefied amazement so if you
are a wonder junkie if you believe as
Carl Sagan did that understanding is a
kind of ecstasy if you are hungry for
the sublime learn to control your
attention learn to control your mind
your thoughts because you're creative
and linguistic choices the very words
you use to map your reality feedback
into your reality you are the painting
you are the paintbrush you are the
canvas you are the question you are the
answer to the question you are looking
for you are also my friends the question
you are everything we are everything we
are sentient we are consciousness the
most sublime miraculous thing in the
universe so you better be having a good
time and authoring your fate turn your
life into a living breathing work of art
because anything less would be a tragedy
[Music]